You are listening to
radiolab radio from W N Y s.
C
hey man, how are ya? Very well. So
Aaron set this up. Who we about to meet?
So this is skip Sherry. He
lived in Brooklyn and that is,
we should say Aaron
Scott, he's a reporter.
We turned us on to skip and Aaron met up.
Was skipped because he had this experience
that common to a lot of people who
moved to New York City. Just tell
us where you, where you grew up.
I grew up in the country
outside of Athens,
Ohio on 54 acres of wooded land and I
would work all day as a kid in the heat
hoeing and picking strawberries,
hauling water, planting trees.
He'd play in the woods. I loved the woods,
but as he got older he knew he
couldn't stay in Athens. Why not? Well,
he's a musician. He wanted
to make a living at it.
So he bounced around for a bit.
I finally find them finally at age 30
there was no place to go except for New
York's. It wasn't a matter that
you wanted to live in New York,
New York was your last, my
last option and he hated it.
It was ugly to me. You know,
like, like which too many humans.
Too many. Too much concrete. Yeah. No.
One theory about autism is that the things
that come into an autistic kids brain
all have equal value. They don't
know how to sort through it.
And when I first came to New
Yorker was, it was really,
it is pretty overwhelming.
I did decide to leave for sure,
but then take us to the roof.
I was lucky when I first moved here,
so he's staying with a friend who lives
in this big building in Brooklyn Heights
right across from the twin towers.
It is 36 stories high and he decides
one lonely night to go up onto the roof.
And there was this intense fog
[inaudible]
in the twin towers. The bottom of them
was covering the fog but not the top.
So it was like they were flooding.
There's little like a cuticle sliver
of moon in the sky and the foghorns are
going in. The boats are slowly moving
[inaudible]
and there's this Rees and I had this,
this brass penny wasn't that my father
had given me and I was standing there.
I was playing it and that I was really
suddenly something clicked. I was like,
oh, that must, those are all the bridges.
That's the Williamsburg Bridge.
That's the Manhattan bridge.
There's the Brooklyn Bridge
that New York, it's small now.
[inaudible]
and I'm looking down at the Statue
of Liberty and my grandmother,
Anastasia Patty came from Albania
and they went to Ellis island.
I could see my history there too and I
was suddenly hit me like, oh my goodness,
this is like a coral reef.
You can't see the people,
but look at this beautiful strip
fog in the air.
It was just the whole city was breathing
[inaudible] the whole nature was
beating. Everything was
[inaudible] breathing.
I felt connected on a spiritual
level to the city for the first time.
[inaudible]
and so skip decided to stay for awhile,
for awhile. All over the
world. People are now moving.
Of course we know this from the
country to the city at this point,
the world two years ago across
this extraordinary benchmark.
That's physicist Geoff West.
We're more than half of the planet is
now urbanized 51% and that made us wonder
how do cities work?
Is there some deep organic logic that
holds all these people together or is
writer general era puts it or cities,
just these tumors that
people on the landscape
[inaudible]
I'm Janna. Boom, Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and our topic today,
cities, cities. I loved
it, but I don't know why
[inaudible].
All right. So in talking about cities,
it's Kinda hard to know where to start
because every city has its own DNA,
kind of its own unique feel.
Yeah.
Like for instance, let me just give
you my own stupid example here.
So every time I go to St Louis to visit
my mom, yeah, I'm gay, I'm on the plane.
I mean my own kind of groove and I step
off the plane into the airport and it's
just like with the first step you just
hit this wall of something is different.
Like you feel the difference in your
bone because let's the question I,
is he there? Right. I'm here.
What gives the city its feel?
Oh is this Mr Bob Levine?
This is Mr Rob Levin.
Mr Bob Levine is a professor of
psychology, California State University.
And he thinks the answer to
that question is time. Time.
Did each city warps time
in its own unique way?
Why should these are my subjects? No,
he studied this idea for the past 30
years in all kinds of different ways.
We looked at things like a
percentage of people wearing watches.
How long does it take bank tellers in
each city to change a $20 bill? Really?
Yeah. And then we, we, we looked
at talking speed. Hawkings yeah.
We'd get on the phone and uh,
called post offices since that seemed
like something that would be available
every place and make a standard request.
What'd you tell me the difference
between regular mail certified mail and
insured mail. Okay. Certified is when
you just need someone to sign for it.
Then he says they'd calculate the
number of syllables per second
regular mail. Just close your
mail. You know at the out of Utah,
Salt Lake City, Utah,
2.73 syllables per second.
Then if you want bootcamp
receipt car to come back
to your house, Springfield
mass time on the phone.
Yes, 3.4 or five syllables per second and
certified is when you want,
not really sure where it's from because
the tape lost the id but it could be
Nashville,
her failing and nick would want to
know who you want to return more three
and if it is Nashville, 2.65 syllables
low. Well Springfield is like fume,
but the whole talking thing was
just really a prelude for Bob.
It got him into what he,
I think he's most known for and
what we find most fascinating. Uh,
we actually looked up at
walking speed walking.
Yeah. Well what I would do is I would
get into a new city. I am in Mumbai,
India, Jerusalem, [inaudible]
Chiang Mai, Thailand.
We actually put out a call to
radio lab listeners everywhere.
We in Buchanan in Liberia to
help us repeat the study. Hey,
good morning Radiolab. I'm recording
from Dublin in Ireland, downtown Oslo,
Copenhagen. Why are we getting
to a new city? And step one,
I would scope out main
business and shopping near
[inaudible] street step to get
out some street or roll of screen.
I red strings, 60 feet long.
20 meters means over here we
wouldn't say feed really. Step three,
use that string to
measure out the distance.
You just have to roll out this and you
take the one end to the sidewalk and I
would just make a mark step four and go
under covers. Get into Carter and uh,
it'd be cool, you know, act like you're
reading a paper or waiting for somebody.
Alright, found myself a discrete
place. Found a pretty nice spot here.
You use a stopwatch? I would
use a stopwatch. Stopwatch.
It's trusty beef watches working.
Ready? Oh, you're ready? Boots. Okay,
I'm ready.
Wow.
I don't know what goes quiet the
minute I want to start. Brilliant text.
Delvin this experiment was actually harder
than you would think. I love people.
This is not very easy to
do. Timing was an issue.
People trying to sell you stuff. Oh
No, no. I don't need this too shy.
Betty Boucher. I look in my corner. I
just don't, can't, no patients don't care.
Okay.
Are you ready? Boom. All together. Now,
Doug Walks. Step, step, step, step, step,
step, step, step.
Actually, it didn't sound like
that at all. They weren't in sync.
As you can imagine, every
city had its own beat guard
snippets. Yes, yes, yes,
yes, Yep, Yep, Yep, Yep,
Yep. Which on some level we knew still
change was pretty amazing. Stop.
Tough line to Oslo. 14.4 seconds.
27 seconds. You Canon, Liberia. Wow.
So team 0.8 Wayne is
Eris 12.13 Mexico City,
10.1 seconds. Copenhagen,
21.5 seconds. Yeah.
Nine 11.57 Portland thing and
a half seconds. Jerusalem.
Just to break it down on the
high end, you've got steps,
steps you're on it's step, step,
step, step. That [inaudible] steps.
She was 9.5 and that's 10.4 who take on
average 10.76 seconds to cover 60 feet.
Compare that to Buchanan.
Liberia step, step, step,
step, step, step. Let's get around
something that actually own the head.
So you've got a teen pink blouse whose
walkers covered the same distance in
about 21 seconds, 21 seconds.
So if you want to think
about it in football terms,
by the time the Dubliner has scored
a touchdown, the gripe from you,
Kevin Lay Bierria is somewhere I guess
around midfield like in this spooky thing
according to Bob Levine is if you
do these under the same conditions,
same place, you will get the same time.
These times don't change.
Dublin is always about this steps you're
on. It's step, step, step and Buchanan.
Liberia is always around
this yet step, step,
step Manhattan is we
found is right about here.
And usually that step with
thunders step, step, step in pink,
no Dublin but not bad. But why
the consistency, what is it?
What is it that makes that walking speed?
Yeah. Where does it come from? You know,
I mean there's anybody beating the drum.
How well can you change the walking speed?
Say a bunch of us got together and decided
that we were just gonna up it by 5%
on a given day. Will we
get everybody to do it?
And will they even notice the
difference? Do we make the city
or just the city? Make us
thank you to our blockers.
[inaudible] who's the faculty?
Liberia. Jerusalem. Eric. Killer
man. And Copenhagen went to Oslo.
Scott, Portland, Oregon. Harry Sante
Nacho. Thailand. [inaudible]. Yes.
Go City [inaudible] in Mumbai. Mark.
I'm Nolan. I'm Dublin in Ireland.
Perhaps also to Daniel Estrin
and an assessment. I don't know,
cause they didn't, they didn't say their
name. Put them in there. Okay. Okay.
So getting back to that
question I asked a second ago,
why is it that cities develop
particular be yes. I mean,
is it because the city does it to the
people or the people do it to the city?
Yeah. And we ran into a couple
of guys who may be released,
have the start of an answer.
Yes. No, a couple of physicists,
oddly enough high named
Jeffrey West and Leash Benton.
This is Jeffery and there's Lewis on
the other side of the table. Cool.
Here at the Santa Fe Institute in New
Mexico and lots of bases and stuff.
Nothing like the cities we just visited.
It's almost biblical in its expanse.
Yeah,
but blue skies just sort of make you
brave and potassium and all those good
things. Brave enough. In fact, to
claim from their high desert Birch,
that eas beats the meter of every city
that we've just been to actually has
underneath it a kind of logic,
if you told me the average speed of
walking in some city x or Rochester New
York,
where walk at about this 60 feet
and 12.67 seconds different,
don't tell him Rochester.
You just tell him the number of beats and
we'll tell you the population is maybe
one and a quarter billion
people, actual population,
1.0 3 million people and the average
weight for about $16,000 a year.
Actual average wage, $15,588 wow.
But let me ask you a precise question.
Are you 100% correct? Are
you pursuing some things?
You will score close to a
hundred percent other things, 80%
but if you start with just the
number of footfalls per unit of time,
they can tell you all kinds of
other things about the same place.
I can tell you how much crime
there is in the city. Income wages,
GDP number college's restaurants,
[inaudible], restaurants, theaters,
police number patents that are being
produced, cultural events per capita,
number of theater that libraries,
the number of aids cases
it's going to have this year.
All of these things are
correlated in a quantitative,
and I use the word predictive fashion.
Wait,
are you saying that just from the number
of footsteps per given time that you
can tell? Can you tell me how
many libraries there are? Yes.
Could tell me how many you should expect.
How many things can you count
when you're infinite number, but,
but it's limited by the things
for which there are data.
They've got data from the u s
census, that's Jonah Lehrer.
He's written about Luis and Jeff and
he's the one that Kinda got us thinking
about all this paper from Japan,
China data from sociological
surveys on cell phones.
And when they put all these numbers
together, they discovered a deep pattern.
It's call comes from the flood zone,
not the footstep. What do you mean?
Having the footsteps are a reflection of
this deep and fundamental pattern that
governs everything. Just one fact.
What is it you really want to
know? Yeah. What is it? Size.
Size. How many people live there?
Size matters.
Size is the largest determinant of
all characteristics of the city,
right?
They would say, tell me
the size of the city,
and I can explain the vast majority of
all these different variables that we can
measure as a city scales up. They say
100,000 to 200,000 the million to 2
million from 5 million to 10 everything
about it. All those things that they'd
been measuring, they scale up too,
but they scale up according to a
very simple mathematical formula.
It does not matter that New York has big
skyscrapers and is on the ocean and the
Boise's in the rocky mountains that
San Francisco is on San Francisco Bay.
Wait a second. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. That can't be. They can't be. I'll,
I was with you right up until
the last two. That last point.
I mean you go to the Midwest and it's
landlocked and then you go to a port city
and it's on a port. I mean
that's got to matter. It matters.
But these actually are superficial effects
and account for only 10 20% of their
variation. What they're saying
is that those specificities, the,
the local history is in
large part insignificant,
but it is completely overwhelmed by
these generic laws of urban scaling.
That to me is a very interesting and
surprising idea simply because we don't
think of cities like that at
all. No, we certainly do not.
That's because you're not a physicist.
So you don't think abstractly in
that we're guard. Well, why should I?
Because sometimes it can be very useful.
Remember what these guys have done is
they've just created eight average profile
for every size city. So if you're a
1 million or 7 million or 12 million,
here's how many things you should
have. Now you can ask, okay,
let's look specifically that city and ask,
is it overperforming or
underperforming? Right.
So what are some cities that are
over-performing for their size, uh,
of the largest cities? San Francisco
is quite an innovative city.
New York is about average
in terms of patents, terms,
New York's below average juices.
Roughly speaking the number of patents
it should for a size you produce for
example, a about uh, twice as
many patterns as Boston we do.
That's something you should have produced
many more given the size difference
between about what average could they'd
counting patents, I mean who may,
who do we don't have engine.
This is one of the problems
with their larger theory,
which is that no attention to that
they're relying on your data at the u s
census collected. So that's a real
blind spot. Counting fabulous.
If we ever can figure out a way to
account. Fabulous. Yes, he has a point.
You're not taking into account with it
actually the experience of living in a
place, well, what this one,
a theory cannot do is tell you
about the essence of New York,
the New York Ness of New York,
so to speak, the soul of the city.
And where does that come from?
Who knows? I mean, I think that's
such a broad question. Well,
obviously it has something to do with
lots of people being jammed into a tight
space environment, bumping into each
other, kind of people who moved there.
What the physicists we
call human friction.
And that's a story you can't really
tell in math. But yeah, you can hear it.
Take skip.
He gave producer Aaron Scott a
tour of his block in Brooklyn,
listen to who he pumps into everyday.
So he took us on this tour. Okay.
First place we went was this Jamaican
body shop. Body shop is in cars. Yeah.
Religion specialists. I mean
it's basically these, you know,
western, these Jamaican guys
listening to [inaudible]
and hip hop reggae.
I like all kinds of music.
It's like it's one place and a
cross across the street from this as
kindergarten, hidden orthodox
Jewish cookie bakery.
And, and I'm disappointed from
that. It's a butcher that, um,
sells live goats and chickens
and here are the goats.
And on the corner of
the Hispanic Pentecostal church,
every Sunday they give it up to God
with this exceedingly enthusiastic
[inaudible]. And I huddle at the window
and I think this is the
best music in the world.
I feel that deeply.
And then across the street
from that one is a mosque.
Whoa. Whoa.
It was beautiful on the inside. Wow.
Across the street there's
this big building and the
proprietor of this space is
a gay foot fetish film producer.
Show me your feet. Show me your feet.
Two 80 something. He's got Jamaicans,
orthodox Jews and the cookies.
Hispanics, Jesus, Allah,
goats in gay porn. Show me your
feet all on the same block.
Absolutely. For me, that's the hammer.
The nails. That's the wrong gradients.
Now I'm gonna take that home and
I'm gonna Assemble it into a song.
And when you heard his music,
could you hear all that stuff?
Some of it is clear than others.
[inaudible]
the sounds of the neighborhood, like
the reggaeton music of the West indies,
auto body shops.
He kind of takes them and then filters
it through some device that makes it
sound like vowels.
[inaudible].
Oddly enough,
the day that Aaron spoke with skip was
the day skip decided he's leaving New
York City and he put in his notice,
which I guess makes his latest album,
sonic New York, kind of a
dear John Letter to the city.
You can hear it on our website,
radio lab.org and Robert Levine's book
for one about walking and time and stuff.
Yeah, it's called the geography of time.
More information about that too
on our website. radiolab.org also,
you can subscribe to our podcasts there.
This is Robert Levine.
I been told that the radio lab is funded
in part by the Alfred piece on donation
and produced by W NYC
and distributed by NPR.
Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich. Radiolab
is supported by Squarespace.
The simplest way to create
a website this new year,
make your next move with Squarespace.
Whether that's starting a business
or launching a passion project,
no matter what your goals are.
Squarespace's award winning templates
can help you present your ideas to the
world.
Beautifully use offer code Radiolab for
10% your first purchase of a Squarespace
domain or website, squarespace.com
make your next move.
Make your next website.
Hey, this is jad from
Radiolab. We're having a, uh,
we're celebrating a little
milestone over here at radio lab.
We have been doing this, we're
making stories for the podcast,
for the radio for 15 years at is
15 years of stories about like,
um, I don't know, the science of morality,
the metamorphosis of butterflies,
legal foundation for the war on
terror. All these different stories.
I've been doing it for 15 years.
So check out our latest episode out of
the archives and all of our episodes are
available wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, I'm Janet [inaudible].
I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab and our
subject right now is cities.
So far we've tried to pin down the
character of a place with math or with a
story or with some music.
Woo.
But it's like trying to take a snapshot
of something that's growing and changing
all the time. And that
feeling that skip had
up on the rooftop, like
the city with breathing.
Maybe the city really
is like a living thing.
Well, yes, in some ways that's
exactly right. The evolve, the grow.
Think about it as Jeff West, every
day, every minute, incomes, energy,
food, trucks, water people
out goes garbage ideas,
songs, stories, people,
energy in, energy out, energy,
energy, Huh?
That's just what a city
needs to do. Sit Jeff
quote, metabolize food, so
to speak, cause without that,
organisms and cities and
so on will simply decay.
So how does a city stay a lot?
What does it really
take for a city to grow?
Well that question got me
thinking about New York and led me
to a place I'd been
wanting to go for awhile.
Thank you.
[inaudible] I think you're
the reverb a little bit.
Where are you underground?
Oh, a hundred feet under
brown.
So this is the sound of one of
New York City's water tunnels.
I'm standing in it. It's exactly
what you would imagine. A big tube.
It's about nine feet wide, nine feet up,
perfectly polished cement. And uh,
it seems to just go forever.
So this is basically a,
like you might call a smaller artery
inside the city's circulatory system.
When this is online in a couple of months,
it will pump up to 290
million gallons a day,
something like that,
which is an awesome thought in the
literal sense of the word. It's uh,
when you walk through the streets in
Manhattan, this is Catherine Mallon,
the Department of environmental
protection.
These water tunnels are anywhere
from 200 to 800 feet below your feet.
They just there and they're silently
there. And when you turn on your tap,
can you take a drink?
You are basking in a daily
convenience that is born from blood,
sweat and death.
To explain, you really have to go back
to a time when there were no tunnels.
Success would be uh,
1790 1800 or so around that time says
historian Diane Galicia in New York's
population was booming,
tripled and 20 years.
And you suddenly had a 100,000 people
all getting their water from the same
spot. A large freshwater
pond called the collect.
And they had pigs running around by the
hundreds and the chamber pots out in the
streets and there were livestock
and lower Manhattan at the time.
People had cows for milk.
And so when they died,
they had to do something with them.
So often she says they'd throw their dead
cows and everything else in the pond,
the same pond that they were
drinking from right now,
not surprisingly, as the city grew,
people got sick in 1798 there
was this yellow fever epidemic,
killed a couple of thousand people and
cholera and typhoid city officials were
like, this has to change. And uh,
as if to accentuate the point in 1835
there was this huge fire and the fire
department rushes out to put
out the fire, but they can't.
It was in December and the rivers froze
and they couldn't get water to the
fires. If you don't have water to
fight the fire, the city burns down.
It's pretty simple. Yeah. 700 buildings.
So that's our starting point in
New York City that could not grow.
And by the way, the guy we
just heard John Chick Donahue,
he's the sand dog part of the long line
of guys who blasted New York out of its
poopy pon phase and into its
future. You ask the question why?
Why are you guys cold?
Sandhogs why won't you be cold tunnel
blasters or earth movers or something
that's more, do you have any idea
where that name came from? Yeah,
it comes from the dictionary
really and I loved the look in people's
faces when they asked me that and I,
that's the answer.
It's described in Webster's dictionary
as a laborer who digs or works in sand
originals sandhogs with the
soft ground guys compressed air.
That's where you need
to backup for a second.
When the city decided to scrap the pond
in favor of clean water from upstate,
it faced a couple of challenges
and this is also true.
When they decided to build the subway
system, namely nature, like how do you,
for example, build a tunnel under a
river? Well, they was San hucks, Jamie.
Dan laid
literally Doug with what we call
muck sticks, shovels on the ribbon,
50 60 a hundred feet under the bottom
of the ribbon. Men with shovels,
excavating ground. That's Nick's
socal. I'm a tunneling engineer.
Generally it's a dark dank
please. Now the obvious engineering
problem is that the river bottom,
which is now above their heads is
soft sands and silts and gravels.
How do you keep that from
not falling on your head?
That's when a compressed
air started being used.
The basic idea says nick is these huge
pumps would basically pump air into the
tunnels at such pressure that it
would basically push the ceiling up.
Exactly. So the mind doesn't
cave in on you. Yeah,
it compressed their holes. That
thing from collapsing in on.
Usually the engineers on the shore had
to get the pressure just right says
chick. Cause if they didn't, you get
this absolutely terrifying situation.
That is maybe the best
cocktail party story ever.
We used to give an award, we
haven't given it many years.
We call it the Marshall
may be award there.
We're doing one of those
tunnels to Brooklyn
[inaudible].
The men are weapon, the face
of the tunnel digging away
very suddenly.
There's a blowout in the face of the wall.
Puncture hole develops tiny at first,
but it quickly becomes bigger and bigger
until it's the size of sort of like an
eye. Then a whole head and all the
compressed air rushes into that. Okay. Oh,
it would be like if you shot
a hole through an airplane.
All the air with shoal hats are flying
into this whole lanterns shovels.
Then a guy goes into the hole guy. Yeah,
a human being into the whole food
and another guy. Boom. Then a third,
the third guy must've been the
luckiest sand hog in the world.
This is an article from the New
York Times as I struck the mud.
It felt as if something was squeezing
me tighter than had ever been squeezed
before. He blew through
all at 60 feet of water
and through the ribbon.
Yup.
To the surface. The pressure
blew him right up into the air.
You're telling me I was thrown about 25
feet above the water when I came out,
but I don't remember that.
That's remarkable. Anything
back down and landed right alongside
a police boat in the one in the water.
So they took him, cleaned him up, he
went home, he came to work the next day.
That's why they gave him the
award. That's why the ward is now.
I'm not kidding you.
In the early days,
no one kept track of how many people
died building New York's tunnels the
number. It's probably in the thousands.
So wait, this, this right here,
this plaque that we're looking
at, this flack was a donated.
This is Richie fits in and
sees the current head of
the sandhogs union and we're
standing in front of a big stone
plaque with two dozen names.
So your memory of all the, uh,
people that we lost in tunnels in
New York City since 1970, you know,
since we started keeping records,
small little photos. Come on here
later. He showed me a picture,
which really underlined the point.
It's a picture of him on his first
compressed air job. Oh Wow. Look at that.
This is myself. He's 19.
He's huddled with five other guys and
they're in this crowded tunnel and they're
all black was said, and he
points to each guy in turn
dead, dead, dead, dead,
had cancer still alive, still alive.
If you ask any of the
sandhogs why they do this,
mostly they'll tell you what we've got to.
The city can't grow without its tunnels.
But you also get answers like
this from chick. If he says,
when you're down there and it's pitch
black and you're just walking the wall.
Yeah, 600 foot under Manhattan,
you're approximately
30th screen or something.
You're in the middle of the
greatest city in the world.
Nobody even knows you exist.
Nobody has it. Nobody has a clue.
It just
beautiful.
It's just that a, it's a weird place.
It's like being on a planet somewhere.
He says when he's literally in this
rock that is half a billion years old,
he sometimes feels
very
humble. Yeah. We're in the middle
of the art then. Yeah. This is,
you want to see nature. If it is, that's
real, a romantic way of saying it.
Uh, the human reality of it
is, here's Richie's take.
Remember when you were a kid,
and I used to give you the an farms and
the [inaudible] and farms, we're big.
We are ants.
Aes is so fricking many of them
that if you got a squish a few,
and if they gotta use each other
to step over each other to, to, to,
to keep that whole thing, that's it.
That doesn't sound very grand the way
you're putting it. Like next reality,
our job is to conquer nature. He says,
plain and simple. We're builders.
Human beings are builders.
And collectively there's
nothing that we can do.
Nothing.
Okay.
October 14th, 1842, oh,
it was a huge celebration.
Hundreds of thousands of
New Yorkers Line Broadway.
It was firing of cannon and the
ringing a church bell fireworks even.
And at the end of it all says Diane,
everybody gathered in City Hall Park
and they turned a big fountain on and
[inaudible]
water shot 50 feet into the air.
New York City. We'd never be the
same. Now can finally be a city.
But here's where you start to wonder a
little bit about the real legacy of sees.
What you see almost immediately after
this moment, according to Diane,
is that water usage skyrocketed.
Suddenly you had indoor plumbing,
all the new buildings were being
outfitted with water closets and kids were
playing in the hydrants all day
long. And to make a long story short,
just 10 years later, the
city is out of water again.
So they get to build more tunnels and
then more. And if you follow the water
in those tunnels, backup state,
you see that the city has gobbling up
reservoirs one after another, dozens,
which meant it had to
kick people off that land.
Well then called eminent domain.
Their villages would have to be
bulldozed and burned. Cemeteries rooted.
Do you see what's happening?
I mean you could see this city that
we live in as a kind of monster.
Just always hungry,
eat, eat, eat, eat, eat
second. Because like, like there
is another logic available here.
Like if you took all the people in
New York City, all those New Yorkers,
you know, if you had every
inhabitant in New York City,
suddenly left New York City and moved
to small towns all across America,
you would need a ton of
resources to make that possible.
That's Jonah lira again,
by the way. So in a sense,
New York City saves lots of forests,
saves lots of water, and the reason why,
well that takes us back to Jeff
and Alecia's ideas about cities.
So I suppose because it all started
years ago, Jeff at the time was studying,
uh, this time was living things.
Let's go back to biology for a moment.
He looked at a huge variety of creatures
and for each one he collected your
data.
Everything from it's a metabolic
rate to length through it's a altar,
how quickly it breathes.
They discovered something kind of
fascinating about creatures as they grow
bigger and picker. If you
double the size of an organism,
you double the number of cells
that need to be sustained.
You would therefore expect that the
energy you need to supply would double.
You've doubled the number of customers
so to speak. Yeah, yeah. No, no.
That is not the case. Instead of doubling,
it needs less energy per unit cell
to sustain the whole organism.
So there is,
I don't know, let's wait a
second. That means that the,
that the sale is somehow
doing more with less. Right.
Does it also mean though that an elephant
cell somehow is more efficient than a
mouse cell? That's correct. Huh.
And Jeff says, the way they do that,
it's pretty simple. They just move slower.
I process energy at a slower
rate. So if you take a mouse cell,
a cell that lives in a
mouse and does its work,
it brings in resources without the waste.
Bringing in more resources spits out the
way it does this with particular beat.
But now says, Jeff, if you
listen to an elephant cell
[inaudible]
he means no,
it's more than
obviously slower. So it's
using less energy [inaudible]
given moment, which
makes it more efficient.
And what does that have to do with cities?
Turns out cities work kind
of the same way in cities.
You see the same kind of efficiency
when it comes to infrastructure,
electricity, a length of roads, water,
lengths of pipes, lengths of
electrical cables, gasoline,
how much gas is consumed is
the point. The bigger the city,
the less roads you need per capita.
What does per capita mean anyways,
per person, per person,
the less electrical cable
lines you need per capita,
the less gasoline stations you need
per capita, et Cetera, et cetera.
So every unit of pipe carries
more water or more sewage.
Every line of electrical
wire carries more. Jeff,
does that mean then that if, uh,
if I move to a bigger and bigger city,
do I in a sense become greener
the bigger the city I live in?
That's a very interesting,
very good question.
And this is where Lewish and Jeff, I
think the case is still a little bit out.
And even Jonah, it gets
complicated when you ask,
are people more or less efficient?
This is when everybody starts to
throw in all of these caveats and
qualifications, all the variable
qualifications and ambulations and
prognostications and distillations.
Let me just tell you what I think.
I think you'd better. All right.
We all love to talk about how green
we are when we live in cities.
This is something everybody in the city
talks about, right? Because we are,
because we take the subway
and the bus we take,
we don't draw and driving like the most
energy consuming. And listen to me,
the analogy that you just gave
me, it does not work. Okay.
You said that sells as they go from
small bodies to big bodies, slow down.
Well, cities, the opposite happens.
Of course as cities get bigger,
each individual unit in that city moves
faster. Thank you Jonah. We speed up.
That's true. We learned this earlier
and this is not trivial. Okay.
Cause as we speed up, we bump into
more people. We have more ideas,
we invent new things, we want more things.
We want more or more of rivers
from your tastes. New Ideas.
More interactions. More human
friction. More, more choices. Yeah,
a better life. That's what a
city is all about. I, I, I,
is there anything wrong
with that? No, not at all.
But there's all I'm saying is there's
a cost to it that we don't acknowledge.
Western Betancourt did this back of the
envelope calculation where it's long
been known that a body at perfect rest
of you lie on your bed all day in a coma,
you will consume and buy 90
watts of electricity that's cold.
Your basal metabolic rate.
If you're a hunter gatherer living
in some tribe in New Zealand,
you will consume about 240
watts of electricity every day.
Energy just simply to stay alive,
plus the energy you need to
hunt and gather. However,
if you are living in America, the
wattage required to drive your car,
run your computer, make your
clothes, air conditioning,
being able to go to movies on and on
and all of the various things that
constituted our life.
If you add all those up,
your lifestyle requires about 11,000
watts of electricity every day, so that's,
that's more energy than in blue whale
requires. Now, some of you listening,
if particularly if you're an engineer,
you may think, wait a second,
why are you calling these watts?
When it's power through a system power
through a human, call them jewels,
the technically correct word. And
then you'd be right, wouldn't you?
But the numbers are the same. So
let's, we'll just call them lots.
So one way to look at what cities have
enabled us to do is basically live like
300 million blue whales in America.
Are you sure that cities are
causing this development?
That it begins and ends with cities?
And you can't assign it all to cities,
but that psychology of
wanting more, that's a city.
It's why people come to cities and then
the lifestyle that grows up around that
gets broadcast out on TV
and radios and movies,
which are city industries to the country.
And if you just take a
historical look at this,
like the last 300 years have seen more
and more consumption, right? Yeah.
And that trend, it's, it's,
it's grown in neat parallel
with the growth of cities. Um,
cities have enabled that kind of
growth. Even if you guys are are,
are right and we know that half of the
planet already is living in cities,
80% of America. So yes, there are
more people. I agree with that.
More choices asking for more consumption,
more energy, more, more, more, more,
more, even if that, so cities,
because they also are ingenious and
they come up with all these new ideas,
maybe cities will solve
the problem right now.
Jet someone somewhere in Calcutta is
about to invent the super light bulb
elevator telephone pipe that will make
it possible for another 200 controlling
people to live together in peace,
harmony, and beauty until the next round.
All right,
you go ahead and claim to that optimism
and you of course can go hang yourself.
So we'll be right back. I remember
crawling. That's Jab Radiolab.
This is try and con
the city of brotherly love.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
hey, I'm Janet. Boom,
rotten. I remember grill,
which this is radio lab and our subject
today is cities and if cities are like
organisms and one thing we should say
about every organism that's ever been,
they die. Yeah they die. So you would
think cities would die, you would.
But Jonah says no, cities die very,
very rarely and they almost never die
if there hasn't been a total total
catastrophe. Physical
catastrophe, which is weird,
you know if you think about it,
it says Jonah cause like take a company
and sometimes it can get very big so
that they include hundreds of thousands
of employees and yet they die all the
time. Of the 30 companies
and the original Dow Jones,
only three are still
on the Dow Jones Index.
If you took 30 cities from the 1920s
I can guarantee you all 30 of those
randomly selected cities would still
exist on the map. And the question is why?
Why don't they die like every
other social organization?
What is it about cities that
gives them this crazy persistence?
That question led us to a place that by
all measures should have died long ago.
A place called Centralia.
Okay, so we begin on the
side of where are we?
We're on route 61 in eastern Pennsylvania.
Right. This is bad, by the way.
He's a producer at radio lab. I know
who pat is. Thank you very much. Anyhow,
we're waiting for this guy named Tom
to meet our professors. He, Tom? Yeah.
Tom [inaudible] asked you, are you
doing okay yet? It's up to you guys.
When did you get her? Just now.
Just now. Just happened to be,
can we ask Tom to show us around
his town? Probably the best place.
He goes up on the hill up
there and look, you know,
you could look over
everything. Okay, sure.
So we go up on the hill with Tom. We
actually meet up with another time.
I'm Dempsey. I was the former postmaster
here. We now have two toms, Tom, Tom,
or confusing.
Any of the four of us stare down into a
valley that used to have a town in it.
Front of house was all, it was all
streets with homes on them all over.
Now Centralia is just trees right down
here was the a Tom two points system.
Trees are a high school
over here. More trees,
flooding nation's church are still
shooting playground right at the bottom of
this little hill right here.
You can still see the bars.
This is where things get a little strange.
I mean right next to the swing set where
kids used to laugh their little heads
off. There's a hole in
the ground right there.
I can see some steam coming out of the
ground spewing steam and that and I would
later discover and we got close to
it that that steam was really hot.
It's hot and wet. Oh My god, Ha.
What? Where exactly is
the fire underneath this?
Like how far here? 50
feet, maybe 50 feet down.
If it is, the smell doesn't bother you
guys. What? Smell? You can smell it.
It smells like burning tires here.
That must be from New York. That's
stuck in your nose. Come on.
It really did smell put.
The thing no one can deny is that
underneath our feet there's a web of coal
mines that stretches from miles
40 miles in each direction,
30 miles and somewhere in those mines is
a fire that's been burning for 40 years
and has either destroyed this town
or not depending on who you ask.
This is pat right here.
My name is Mary Lugandan.
I'm 82 years old and I lived in
Centralia most of my adult life.
What year were you born in? If you
mind me asking, what year was I born?
1927 Mary Lou gon grew up in a
town not too far from Centralia.
Really neat little farm
town called Burnsville and
when she got to central Ella
she said was like moving to the city.
It had a legion drug store. It had that.
It had a couple thousand people,
lots of bars was in center and somebody
told me one time there were 22 bombs in
Centralia. I don't know if that
was true cause I didn't frequent.
Byron's at that age and all these places
that you just mentioned were right on
top of each other. So when
you were walking around,
you'd see people all the
time. Just take, for instance,
you'd go to the post office after work
and show you where the post office was.
Tommy would be there sometimes. I was
postmaster here for a number of years.
Tweet. You're pointing into a
forest. It's hard to imagine this.
It is hard to imagine,
and yet I walk to the post office
because your mail wasn't delivered,
so I'd go up to the post office and get
my mail and you'd meet people in the
post office. You'd meet people
coming out of the post office.
This was a good football field
here. Now it's all growing in.
Nobody's cutting the grass. There's bushes
growing up in it now, Tommy Dempsey,
to have his story, I would be an
hour till I got home. Whole hour.
This is house and was. Okay.
Fast forward, it's Memorial Day,
1962 this is where the borrowers
just picked up all their garbage.
Magnify the star that I'd say just about
right here where I'm standing right
now. Tell me points to a little
patch of nondescript yellow grass.
Like why here? How did it start?
Do we have any idea? Well,
it started the most
likely scenario. He says,
we also heard this from a
writer named Joan Quigley,
author of the day the Earth gave him,
is it people used to heat their homes
with coal and maybe somebody threw their
ashes into the garbage, which
then ended up onto the dump.
It caught the whole thing on fire,
furniture, rugs, kerosene camps,
which John says wasn't that unusual?
Some of the former firefighters said out
the dumps caught on fire all the time
and usually the virus just fizzled
out on their own. But this one,
for whatever reason before it did
wandered a little bit and it found its way
over to an old exposed, exposed call
vein there. Basically an old strip mine.
Yeah. It should have
been covered but wasn't.
So there was just a big open cavity
when the fire got in there and okay,
that call, the
fire trucks came up here and a hose down
the fire until they thought it was out
and they left following
Betty. Somebody says, all,
we see smoke and steam coming
out of the ground up there.
[inaudible] came back the next day and
they tried to get the fire out and they
couldn't very well do it or they weren't
getting it cause at that point it was
too, I wouldn't know where
to start with this mind far.
I wouldn't know where to start. The
first place that fire came down,
it was right underneath Mary Lou's house
and from that point on it kind of took
over her life. Oh my goodness. Is
Your scrapbooks. When we were there,
she pulled out these
two gigantic scrapbooks.
Is it gonna take for
men to lift this book?
Each book is literally three feet tall
and they document in painful detail.
How that fire split the town in to,
this is how intense I was with
this mindful fire that she heaved,
opened the book and she showed us this
picture of three people crouched on the
street in front of a
whole, this is my husband,
my son and me and husband
holding a thermometer.
We dropped this down on it like a
fishing pole down on a like you're ice
fishing. Yeah.
This is their way of measuring
the temperature of the
fire bill up and what did
we read? It was pretty high.
A hundred degrees high.
850 or something under your
house? No, this was on the street,
but the street right in front of her house
and the garage. The garage was right.
As you can see, that
garage here is right there.
She showed us another picture
of her standing in her
garage in front of a trench
that they'd dug in inside that
trench. You see flames. Oh,
we used to go out at night and
watched there that, you know,
the glowing and the ambers fire up
there got so bad that some of Marilu's
neighbors actually got government money
to leave their houses name where the
first people bought out. Never once,
like at the beginning did you think like,
oh, maybe we should just get outta here.
No, there's a fire a hundred yards.
Yeah, never. Yeah. I never went to, no.
Instead she did exactly the opposite.
My husband, and this was a big official
and this was the beginner heals,
started writing letters, men Nelligan
Musto. We wrote letters to him.
We talked on the phone with him. I
couldn't tell you all the congressmen.
We talked before, governors,
all the Harrisburg officials and they
were promising everything but the sun.
But it never happened. But other than
the people who lived on that street,
then many,
many people in town didn't have to
worry or even think about the Mindfire.
Nobody ever believed that the fire
was, was even serious in some tragedy.
My husband, myself and Helen, rumor,
it's uptown and the fire is uptown.
All that changed on Valentine's Day.
1981 we're up a little bit
hotter because of this guy,
fellow named Todd Demboski,
who at the time was just a boy.
I was 1212 year old boy. He's playing
outside in his grandmother's backyard.
I noticed a small wisps of
smoke coming out of the ground,
so he went over to take a look. I
was like, I bent down to investigate.
I noticed that my feet
were starting to sink in.
It was really soft and
it was like quicksand.
The more I tried the struggle and more,
ah, I was just opening the hole larger.
He wound up sliding to my
thighs, to my waist until he was,
I was under all the way underground
surrounded by hot steam.
Smoke was so intense. Now
it's like rotten eggs. Oh,
well.
I was screaming for my cousin and his
cousin heard him and came running over,
blocked me out like a flower.
What happened to him? Changed everything
because suddenly reporters were
everywhere. Reporters from the evening,
Harold's Nightline, national news media,
everybody pointing their cameras at Todd.
I see smaller flown over to shape
was the mind burn when I did.
I just thought right through and doing
stories about this town that was on fire.
The underground coal fires still burn
Hodgson and isn't inferno federal
attention.
Parts of Centralia look like the outskirts
of hell would focus on what had to
happen for the town. There
wasn't long says Joan before.
Some of the younger residents,
small informal group of young parents
organized in March and look is to have
anyone down the main street in town. How
many people are we talking about here?
Couple of dozen with red ribbons around
their arms and their wrists and they
walked two by two down the main street
of Centralia like striking miners.
Mary Lou glared at them as they passed.
I was bitter. I was bitter with,
they claimed they were for
helping the town to be safe,
but they weren't what they were really
for. She figured was getting out there,
look for funds to get relocated.
She even hated their name,
concerned citizens against the
Centralia mine fire. She thought,
how are they the concerned citizens.
She's the concerned citizen.
She had been fighting the fire for years.
The media was there taking video
cameras, filmed the marchers,
looping red ribbon over everything,
and Mary Lou's neighbor,
Helen cut the red room.
It's down because we fought so
hard to try to save Centralia.
Why did they want to do this? People
like Mary Lou and Helen Willmar.
They started telling people, no,
no, no. Here's why it's safe.
Here's why you should say
parents from the other group were on
TV complaining about gases in the home.
It could be a death house.
It's Mary Lou,
Helen and a few others started up their
own committee and I did Centralia area
mine task force.
They got on TV themselves and in the
community they started putting up flyers,
fact sheets and handing them out. Yep.
Door to door. Okay. On a college meeting,
daughter at town meetings.
The dueling committees would get
up there and make their case,
but this is a borehole get yelled down,
will not protect us when they get old.
They get rowdy. Absolutely
ridiculous. Families fighting against
families, neighbors against neighbors.
There's lambing and you split the town
apart. Who's that? David Lamb. This guy,
David Lamb,
ran a motorcycle shop in town and he
was also a member of this concerned
citizens organization.
[inaudible] early morning and one morning
at about 4:00 AM he was sleeping in an
apartment and someone threw a Molotov
cocktail through his plate glass window.
Mary Lou showed us an article from a
scrapbook related to lamb's activities as
an officer of concerned
citizens. Wow, this is no joke.
This is like the Sopranos,
but worse yet this was really,
it was really bad and in
the midst of all this chaos,
Congress started considering a bill that
would basically let them buy out the
town. Some observers believed
that for about $50 million,
Centralia could be totally bought out
until the mayor decided that idea,
let's hold a referendum,
and the issue was stay or go. In the
weeks leading up to the referendum,
Mary Lou and Helen again went
door to door talking to people.
They'd known their whole lives and
pretty much everyone they talked to said,
I really want to stay.
My mother wants to stay
August 11th, 1983 shortly
before 10 this evening,
Centralia is mayor announced the results.
There is 545 boats, boats, cash,
200 voted to stay.
345 voted to relocate. I was
crying. Yes, in my heart.
I never thought that would happen ever.
You thought that everybody
would would Wednesday,
maybe 40 people might decide or maybe
30 but that was devastating to to know
that so many people want it to move.
It was and when you look at
her scrapbooks, everything
stops after that day.
Yeah. This is just drawn in papers.
Wow. It just stopped so abruptly. Yup.
I was always mad and disgusted
and I didn't want to,
I didn't want to do it no more
about it. That was the end.
Almost immediately after that
vote, Congress bought out the town.
People started packing up and
leaving. Know. Let me see where it is.
I have some,
it has the big numbers that ray Lou
told us that when you decided to leave,
a demolition crew would actually come
to your house and paint big red letters
like this. A big number
one in front of your
house. Like blood was dripping off.
Oh, it's like you were marked. Yeah.
And what would happen?
She says when your house was marked
as that your neighbors would see it,
they'd get nervous and then suddenly
their houses would be marked and then
suddenly the whole block would be marked.
And I knew every one of them
quite well. And I'm thinking,
I stopped talking to some of them.
She'd see him on the street, she says,
and look the other way. I
didn't like any of them really.
[inaudible] and one day
in the fall of 1987,
these divisions caused something to happen
that is just kind of like mythically
bad. Yeah. It involved a married
couple who'd been in the town most.
She'd been there her whole life. And
um, as a couple they were divided.
One wanted to stay, one wanted to go.
I think it was the wife who didn't
want to leave and the husband,
why he was a shovel runner and he,
he wanted to take the money you get
from your location and get out there.
Neighbors were moving,
had moved the houses around them are
being torn down and they had to make a
decision and all we really know is that
at some point they started to argue and
um, and it escalated.
He stabbed her to death with a kitchen
knife and then drove up to an old
stripping pip and set
himself in his car on fire.
Wow.
Is, this is going to sound
like a strange question,
but is there anything about
that that makes sense to you?
Like why couldn't people
let go of this place?
It is very primal.
Beyond that she really couldn't say why.
And we asked Mary Lou who
hung on long after the murder,
after that referendum, after
the town was basically empty.
I have no idea what kept me there. I
have no idea. You have no idea. No,
I knew I just didn't want to move the
other street [inaudible] man banners.
You got houses down there. Yeah. Today,
11 people live in town was
better than his wife, man.
My mom and him lived down
through the intersection.
Tom and Tom pointed them all out from
the hill. We knocked on every door,
figured we asked them what it is that
keeps them living literally on top of a
fire. Hi, good evening.
Wow. That was the shortest, but
none of them wanted to talk to us.
Not even the dogs. Oh, okay. All right.
But then Tom two took us to one last spot.
Where are we right now? You're in San
Ignatius, Roman Catholic cemetery.
The cemetery is just a few feet away
from the hill where we started and it's a
really strange contrast.
You go from this steamy hell and
then suddenly you're in like Woodsy,
Vermont. There's a lot of big beautiful,
this is my grandfather and my grandmother.
Tom has four generations buried here.
Do you know how many people are here, Tom?
There's over 3000 burials and
this time I Terry along 3000 yes.
Plus the thing is says Tom, even
the that left fled that fire,
continue to come back and be buried in
the cemetery, which means this place,
the cemetery is the only thing in
Centralia that's still growing.
[inaudible]
it's suddenly how Joan put it earlier.
It is very primal. Made Sense.
You can experience your life
on a multigenerational planet.
This is where my great grandparents
are buried, which means in a sense,
this town will never die as long
as the cemetery is still here.
Not even read their name on it
this year. This dig it up. Oh,
it's under the dirt.
Do a
get this up by Shauna.
See it sinking down into the ground, but
it's in the, it's in the dirt. No, yes,
yes, no. There we go. We
can see a dem has c y s
y thinks about Walter's for reporting
that with me and also to Chris Perkel and
Georgie Roland who directed
a great documentary about
Centralia called the town
that was, you can find out more
information about that on our website.
radiolab.org I'm Robert
Krulwich. I'm Jad Abumrad. Bye.